Michelle O'Neill why have you decided to
attend the coronation of King Charles
I think it's really really important
that I honor the pledge that I made to
the public and last May's Assembly
Election I said that I would be our
first Minister for all and I think this
is a fulfillment of that promise there
are those in our community that have a
British identity and allegiance to the
market and I think it's important that I
as a first Minister for all can be
respectful of their Viewpoint and also I
can represent all the people in our
community
so it's a political decision rather than
a personal one well it's certainly a
personal commitment to attend but it's
also fulfilling my promise that I made
to the electorate I think that's really
really important that whenever I made
that commitment and a pledge to be first
Minister for all that I actually
followed through in that and I think
this is not an opportunity in which to
do so how significant is it for an Irish
Republican to be in attendance at such a
supremely British event
well there's no doubt republicanism on
the market there are two things that are
very much at odds but again I think
that's just the world we live in we live
in a very changing space and I think
that those of us in political leadership
need to have the confidence from our own
backbone it doesn't
um our own standpoint doesn't diminish
my republicanism to attend the
coronation of the king to be respectful
to those people here over British
identity who look there are political
agencies is pointed that way so I just
think that at these moments in these
junctures it's really really important
that we are confident enough on our own
skin to be able to take initiatives like
this and actually to do something that
demonstrates that I will be first I'm
first Minister for all and someone who
as an Irish Republican can represent um
everybody in our community of course
you've already met the king there was a
very warm exchange between you following
the death of his mother is he a man you
can get along with
well I don't think that's the key I mean
I don't think that's even the issue here
this is about being respectful and about
being mature and I think just
demonstrating by your Deeds that to
those people who look towards the
monarchy then that I would be respectful
of you know of their tradition their
background and who they have allegiance
to and so for me that's important I mean
obviously I've met um with Charles on a
number of occasions in Cork um here last
year in the on the aftermath of the um
death of his mother the queen I think
that was really really important so I've
met him on a few occasions we always
have good healthy conversation he's of
No Doubt of my background and my
political allegiance and my aspirations
for constitutional change in this island
but I think that it's really important
that in political leadership we all be
mature and respectful of each other what
would you say to Irish Republicans who
would find this difficult not least
because the king is commanded in Chief
of the Armed Forces I think there's no
doubt that people find it difficult will
have some difficulty with the decision
and I respect that and I want to engage
with those people that do but I also
would say to people particularly
Republicans we have a constitutional
democratic piece where a pathway towards
Irish Unity I love the kid for that
every day and I think that's really
really important as we move further
towards constitutional change there are
people in our society who very much have
a different political allegiance and who
have a British tradition and I want to
be respectful to those people and that's
why I think this decision at this time
is crucially important in terms of
demonstrating that no one is anything to
fear in terms of change constitutional
change that there are ways in which we
all can live side by side as neighbors
as people who all have an equal status
in terms of this place where we live
this place we call home
still more than a month from the
coronation do you have any hope that you
will be attending as first minister of
Northern Ireland is there any sign of
power sharing returning well I think
that's what the people voted for back in
may they want politics to work they want
us to get around the executive table
they want us to take on the issues of
the day of the things about the Health
Service needing fix you know creating
jobs and opportunity and particularly in
this year that we're in 25 years of the
Good Friday agreement and all that's
been achieved we have something to
celebrate but for me this anniversary
must be about Hope and opportunity and
where we're headed in the next 25 years
so I hope that I will be able to attend
as first Minister but if if that is not
the case I will be attending this first
Minister elect
what if the power sharing government
never comes back
well I'm not counting this in that I'm
determined make choir Sharon work it is
the only show one time and this year
when we celebrate 25 years of the Good
Friday agreement we have to look at the
whole transformation of our society
there is something to celebrate so I
urge and political immunism to join with
the rest of us make politics work sit
around the executive table together
let's do this let's deliver good Public
Services let's fight back against Tori
austerity and let's make politics work
because that's what the people and the
public voted for in mayor's election